- As a young professional,
after a couple of years in your job,
you're hopefully in the position
to earn a decent salary,
and of course, in order to be able
to finance your investments.
Usually saving your income,
saving a significant
portion of your income
is the most important thing,
the biggest lever that you
have to make that work.
In today's video, I'm going to show you
the shockingly simple math
how your savings rate is directly related
to your long-term financial health.
I'm going to talk about the top tips
that I implemented in my life
to keep my savings rate at
50% over the last years.
And I'm going to show
you why this also means
that you do not need to live a frugal,
and minimalistic life
to make all this work.
You can still spend lots of
money on all your pleasure,
so no worries about that,
I'm going to exactly show
you how to make that work.
So welcome to another coffee
break here on my channel.
My name is Heinrich and
here on Firm Learning
I want to help you to become successful
in the first years of your career.
And yes, I do believe
that in order for you to be you
successful in the long-term,
it's not only about you
getting your career, right,
but you need to get your
money right as well.
And this is all about
developing the right habits
to do the right things
without even thinking too much about it.
So now before we jump into today's video,
I just wanna take a moment
to thank the sponsors of this channel.
Very happy to see this list of members
grow even added new persons last week,
so check it out.
So let's check out the math
behind the savings rate,
why the savings rate is so important?
And why the math itself
is not too complicated?
I did find it quite powerful,
the first time I saw these
kinds of calculations.
So here I'm using this calculator
from the page networthify.com.
So check that out as well,
if you wanna play around with
the numbers for yourself.
And let's not put in
the savings rate of 6%.
So let's assume that you
are able to save 6% of that
and why 6%?
So here is a chart and
interestingly enough,
here there not inserted already some data,
what by country now, typical
savings rates would be.
So to be fair the data is a bit old,
but let's just assume that
this is indicatively right
until the numbers are quite low, right?
So for the UK, the average guy apparently
saves only 2% of his income.
For the US it's 6, for
Germany 12, France 16,
interestingly enough in
China 28 and in India 32.
So 6% would be what the
typical guy in the US saves.
So this would mean that every year
the person saves 2,400 Euros,
probably dollar in this case.
So this mode calculates with
some returns of 5% every year,
which seems fair, like a
long-term rate of return
if you're assuming that
the majority of the funds
is invested in the stock market.
And then in the end,
it's assumed that there
was the raw rate is 4%.
So what these values not
tell you is that assuming,
that your income remains
stable in the future.
And assuming that are your
saving rate remain stable,
so you save these 2,400.
And assuming that your
expenses remain stable,
that you will always
expand exactly this amount,
not more, not less, then
it will take you 62 years.
Until your income from your investments
exceeds your expenses.
So in 62 years, you will be in a position
where in perpetuity your income
from your investments alone
will exceed your expenses
and you do not need to work anymore.
Of course, the problem with those numbers
that 62 years is longer
than the professional life
of the normal person.
So you will never reach
financial independence
with this saving rates.
So you need to rely that you
have some other type of income,
some other type of rent when you're old,
or you might need to then
really spend all your savings
if you retire.
And then of course you will not be able
to pass anything on to your children.
Which you might, or maybe also of course
might not wanna do any way in the future.
So let's look like how
these numbers change
if we inserting now the typical
German savings rate of 12%.
We assume that people save 12%,
then this number is already
decreasing to 47.5 years.
So this is the number which
more or less corresponds
to the average professional
life of a person.
But this of course means that
then you will only be able
to reach financial independence
as per the definition that I
just gave you once you retire.
What happens now, though,
if actually able to save
50% of your net income,
this will then leave you with 20,000 euros
in savings every year
and also 20,000 euros in expenses.
Now, of course 20,000 euros in expenses
is not a huge amount,
but this is for sure
significantly more to spend
than I had when I was a student.
And frankly, I had a pretty good life
when I was a student right?
What you see here is that
if you're indeed able
to save 50% of your income,
then you are able to reach
financial independence
or you're able to retire,
if you wanna read the space
on the definition that
your investment returns
cover all your living
expenses in only 16 years.
And this might enable you,
if this is what you wanna do after all
to potentially retire in your late 30s,
if you started working early enough.
Now all of this is of course not to say
that I would recommend
you to start working
in your early 30s or anything like that.
And for sure, I know for myself
that even if I had the money,
I would probably continue working,
but it's fair to assume as well,
that most people probably
would be much more selective
in the type of work they accept.
They would think much more
about what they actually wanted to do,
what their passion really would be.
If you would know that actually
you do not really need to work anymore,
but it's rather because
you really want to.
And this at least for me
was always motivation enough
to keep my savings rate high.
I started doing that pretty
much since the very beginning,
once I started working in Germany.
And indeed I was able to
keep my savings rate at 50%
pretty consistently over the last years.
And I do think that there are a couple
of key lifestyle decisions
that I made for myself,
that really enabled me to do that.
First of all, neither me
nor my wife has a car.
During my professional life
I lived in Berlin, in Munich,
in a small city, in the West of Germany
and a none of these places I owned a car
since I started working.
Here would have had the
opportunity to get a company car
and a quite nice one, frankly.
But in Germany, you need
to pay income tax on that
because cars are considered
as an income equivalent,
if you get company cars
from your employer.
This would have meant an
expense of 700 Euro every month,
so I declined the car,
did not take the company
car to avoid the taxes
that I would have needed to pay.
Instead, I love taking my bicycle,
if I need to go somewhere,
I usually take public transport
when I really need a
car for a day trip or so
I usually just pick one up
in the city for car sharing,
which I find are highly comfortable
and super cost effective solution as well.
Now I do believe that depending
on your life situation,
where you live and also what
your responsibilities are,
sometimes you just need a car
and I fully understand that,
and maybe also in the future,
I might be in a position
where I will get myself a car.
But over the last 10
years, at least for me,
I didn't see the necessity so far.
Next are the housing expenses.
In here what I saw many people do
whom I started working with,
and also some other friends of mine
who are privileged enough
to earn decent salaries.
I saw these people are
moving into larger flats,
moving into really great
and comfortable places
because they could afford it.
This is not what my wife
and I decided to do.
We decided to rather choose
a bit of a smaller one.
So for sure we already
feel super privileged
to live in our current flat,
and we do not really feel
restricted by it at all.
But still our housing expenses
relative to our income
are probably significantly less
than many, many of my peers.
And this is of course, a huge factor
for your savings rate as well.
Next is just your overall
generally consumer spending behavior.
And again, I have many
friends where sometimes
I have the impression they are just bored
and they sit on their
sofa, they take the laptop
and just browse Amazon and just buy stuff
because they are bored.
And this is something that
I really try to avoid.
So whenever there's something
that I really, really crave,
I don't think about it for quite some time
and if then I still really wanted then,
yes, I will get it, but I will
not just browse the internet,
randomly looking for stuff
that maybe I couldn't be interested in.
Next then closely related to
that is the tech equipment
that many people buy and
upgrade all the time.
I know many people who
constantly upgrade their phones,
their Apple watches,
their laptops and so on.
My phone is several years old
and it works perfectly fine.
I use an iMac, which I bought in 2013,
it's still doing a wonderful job.
So I don't try to always get
the newest stuff all the time,
and this for sure saves
me a lot of money as well.
And indeed I do not think
that all these things
really make you happy.
And there's also a concept
for that called hedonic adaptation.
What does hedonic adaptation mean?
Well, if you get yourself a nice new car,
if you get yourself a nice new laptop
or some other great things,
then for a certain amount of time,
you will feel a rush of
endorphins, you will be very happy.
This will bring you joy for some time,
but the truth is you will
not stay at this level of joy
and happiness in the long-term.
Over a certain amount of time,
usually only days,
sometimes even only hours,
your happiness level when
then start to decrease again.
And indeed in the long-term,
it will always come down to
some kind of average level
of happiness that you have in your life,
will just constitutes
the baseline for you.
And if you condition
yourself to think this way,
then the only thing that can
really bring you up again,
it's the newer larger
cars, the newer nicer flat,
but the problem is it never ends.
It doesn't matter what you own,
you will always in the end,
come down to this level.
So these kind of things, while I know
and while I understand
that these are great,
and of course I'm guilty
of all these pleasures as well.
These do not really bring you
sustainable happiness in the long-term.
And for me, once I understood
this, this really clicked,
this somehow made sense to me.
And while again, I do
not want to claim it all
that I'm perfect here
while I waste lots of money
on useless stuff all the time as well.
Though for me personally,
this is also about priorities
about doing the right
things in the right order.
I could very much see myself
in the future getting a car.
In the future maybe
moving into a larger flat.
Maybe buying myself more
of this great new stuff,
but I do not want to be dependent
on my monthly salary to
finance this lifestyle.
I do not want to have the feeling
that if I would lose my job,
I wouldn't be able to do
my car payments anymore.
I wouldn't be able to pay
my monthly rent anymore.
I wouldn't be able to
finance my lifestyle anymore.
This would just make me feel
so dependent on my current job
on my current salary.
And I do not want to do that
I'd rather now focus
on investing the money
on building the financial independence.
And then rather once I've hopefully reach
that in the future, then think more about
where I could maybe spend the money.
So guys pay the price today
so you can pay any price tomorrow.
And if you're not asking
yourself will highly,
how do I need to invest?
Where do you want me to put my money in?
Then of course, besides becoming
a member of this channel, obviously
sign up via the join button below.
Check out the other video that
I did a couple of months ago
on investing as a young professional.
I will link it somewhere above
here for you to check it out.
In this video, I explained
my personal strategy,
how I approach my investments
though, of course, I
wanna also make it clear
that I'm no financial advisor.
So always do your own research
before putting your money somewhere.
Hope this was helpful.
And if you have any questions at all,
please leave me a comment
below in the common section.
And as you know, I will do my very best
to answer every single one.
And if you took any value
out of this video at all,
please hit the like button
for the YouTube algorithm
and also subscribe to my
channel for even more content.
And you can also turn
the notification bell on
to receive notifications
whenever I release a new video,
because otherwise YouTube
might not show you the videos,
even if you subscribe to me.
If you wanna see even more
also follow me on my Instagram,
my handle is @firmlearning,
I upload posts almost daily.
And I also have a mailing
list, you can sign up to that
via the link in the video description.
Again, if you want to
support me and my work
please become a member of this
channel via the join button,
or there's also link in
the video description.
This would mean the world for me.
So big thank you for everybody
who just considers joining.
I'm going to be back next week.
I released weekly videos every Saturday,
so look forward to next week
and until then, bye bye.